das beliebteste Gericht der Welt billig
vs teuer Pizza und ich sage euch so
viele ich erwarte viel vom heutigen Tag
aus dem ganz einfachen Grund wir haben
hier unfassbar teure Zutaten Zutaten von
dem man sich gerade in der italienischen
Küche viel verspricht also tolle für die
larze also besondere Mozzarella
unfassbar teures Olivenöl diese Flasche
hier 43 € und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir ganz normale Discounter
Zutaten billiges Salz billiger Käse
billiges Mehl Dinge mit dem man
vielleicht eine einfache Pizza machen
würde wie groß ist der Unterschied lohnt
es sich so viel mehr Geld auszugeben das
finden wir jetzt heraus ihr seht
vielleicht schon der Pizzateig ist schon
fertig ich habe schon einige Male
Pizzateig gemacht deshalb gehen wir
heute nicht allzu viel darauf ein ich
erkläre euch trotzdem wie es gemacht
habe das hier drüben ist der besondere
Tag das ist der günstige Teig der
Hauptunterschied im Teig das Mehl hier
drüben haben wir das sogenannte
nuvolamail das ist von der besonderen
abmethanischen Mühle eine echte
Innovation weil das besonders viel Luft
im Rand behält und besonders hoch geht
besonders knusprig wird und auf der
anderen Seite heute haben wir ein
klassisches 405er Weizenmehl 79 Cent
3,50€. das ist natürlich schon
Vielfaches aber wie viel beides
insgesamt gekostet hat könnt ihr jetzt
schon mal raten und das lösen wir jetzt
direkt auf wir fangen mit dem günstigen
an 9 Euro 36 klingt nicht nach ganz
wenig dazu muss ich natürlich sagen das
ist der gesamte Einkauf daraus können
wir locker 4 Pizza Margarita ziehen und
eigentlich die teuerste Zutat auch hier
das Olivenöl mit 4 € aber zu einer
richtigen Pizza Margarita gehört halt
auch dieser Schluck Olivenöl oben drauf
für mich persönlich zumindest safe dazu
und kann auch was am Geschmack ausmachen
deshalb so viel zu diesem Preis und hier
was soll ich jetzt erzählen haben wir
die Premium Variante mit 71 € 52 das ist
unfassbar viel und auch hier ist das
Olivenöl mit Abstand die krasseste Sache
dieses Olivenöl kostet 43 € habe ich
euch ja gerade eben schon gesagt aber
ich kann es noch nicht ganz fassen ich
will unbedingt gleich mal so einen Zeit
bei side testen machen von günstigen und
teuren Olivenöl ob ich einen Unterschied
schmecke aber auch die Tomaten haben
natürlich als San Marzahn und Tomaten
330 pro Dose zu Buche geschlagen 10 Euro
für den Käse das Meersalz allein 3,50 €,
wie viel das ausmacht das er schmecken
wir später aber dafür müssen wir ganz
vorne anfangen und zwar beim Teig und
mein Pizzateig habe ich gemacht wie
immer deshalb heute im Schnelldurchlauf
und das könnte ich euch jetzt Zeit bei
side zeigen oder ich zeige es euch
einfach einmal weil es sind genau die
gleichen Schritte unterschiedliche
Zutaten wir brauchen 350g Mehl 225 g
warmes Wasser und einen Gramm
Trockenhefe das alles vermengen wir und
lassen wir über Nacht stehen am nächsten
Tag gehen wir noch mal 350g Mehl dazu
die gleiche Menge Wasser und 18g Salz
das ganze vermengen wir lassen wir ein
bisschen mehr Raumtemperatur stehen dann
portionieren wir es und haben es am Ende
in kleinen fertigen Teigling und so
können wir unsere Pizza backen etwa 24
Stunden Zeit aber es lohnt sich denn
dieser Pizzateig hat mir auf jeden Fall
schon das ein oder andere mal leckere
Pizza beschert wie gut sie jetzt jeweils
sein werden das werden wir sehen auch
hier sind die Unterschiede auf den
ersten Blick zu erkennen auch wenn es
eigentlich das Gleiche ist wenn auch
nicht dasselbe alleine hier
ich bin die ganze Zeit so gespannt ich
freue mich auf diesen Blindtest
eigentlich müsste das direkt als
allererstes machen ich kümmere mich
davor aber erstmal um die Tomatensoße
die ist denkbar einfach guck mal hier
mehr Salz kein Meersalz da glaube ich
jetzt wirklich dass es kann man nicht
schmecken also irgendwie hat mehr so
jetzt schon sowas was cooles so eine
besondere Haptik und so weißt du was ich
mal gehört habe was sind das Meersalz
wohl salziger ist als Jodsalz hat mehr
Salz
hier sind ganze San Marzano Tomaten die
kennt man an den äh Flaschenform und ich
werde jetzt wie es gelernt habe bei
Francesco ja dazu die mit den Händen
zerquetschen warum damit wir nicht die
Kerne in den Tomaten verletzten so dass
sie nicht ihre Bitterstoffe abgeben wie
eine richtig gute Tomatensoße haben den
Spielraum haben wir nicht bei der
günstigen Variante haben einfach die
günstigsten Tomaten gekauft die es gab
das waren jetzt äh fein gehackte aber im
Prinzip sind die auch fein gehackt wenn
ich die durchgequetscht habe das mache
ich jetzt ein bisschen vermengen mit
Salz und dann sind unsere Vorbereitung
eigentlich fertig und dann kann ich
endlich das Olivenöl probieren bisschen
spät und reiche mir den ersten Löffel
schwöre ich werde auch gar keinen Fall
schummeln weil ich will unbedingt wissen
43 Euro gegen vier Euro muss krass sein
ja Unterschied Nummer eins
boah ist krass sehr sehr schwierig zu
sagen weil ich natürlich selten einfach
pures Olivenöl gegessen habe das hat so
eine ich mache mich voll zum Affen wenn
es jetzt weil ich wird direkt dann ist
das teurer aber ich mache mich zum Affen
wenn nicht weil ich habe so richtig
gemerkt dass das hat so meine meinen
Mund gegangen und hat sich so super soft
angefühlt aber dann hinten raus war
schon richtig scharf und ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob dieses echt scharfe schlecht
oder gut ist aber gib mir mal das andere
okay
oh mein Gott okay was war der teure
Löffel und Löffel Nummer eins oder
Löffel Nr 2 ich bin nicht so dumm dass
ich es nicht weiß ich muss wissen
eigentlich nichts ich muss raten ich
sage nur mal zwei weil der Nachgeschmack
ein bisschen angenehmer war nach der
Schärfe war raus aber es ist also
wirklich Leute man merkt wenn ihr keine
ölkonosphäre seid macht mal so ein Test
ich fühle mich ein bisschen dumm weil
ich glaube Leute würden von mir erwarten
auch dass ich das für das ist so der
vierfach Preis der zehnfache
4,5
probiert hat deshalb auch das wird
vielleicht nicht den riesen Unterschied
machen aber vielleicht macht es ja die
Summe aller Arbeitsschritte und aller
Zutaten fangen wir an mit dem ausformen
der ersten Pizza und wir fahren die
erste Pizza aus das ist einfach nur ein
bisschen 10 oder haben wir jetzt bei
beiden Pizzen die gleiche deshalb gehe
ich da jetzt nicht drauf ein jetzt
vielleicht auch noch mal ein paar Euro
rauskitzeln können wir nehmen uns unsere
merken schon jetzt wirklich an der
Oberfläche vom Teig das 45 Mehl
vielleicht
Hefe weil es ist ja auch ein bisschen
nass anderes aber es ist einfach so ein
anderer Teig der ging auch 24 Stunden so
wie unser anderer Teig der verhält sich
schon anders also ich habe ja eigentlich
bisher nur napolitanische Pizza selbst
gemacht das ist streng genommen jetzt
halt kein apotalischer Teig weil kein
tipo Zero Zero und so ich bin einfach
sehr gespannt wie der sich jetzt
verhalten wird wie ich den auch
bearbeiten kann und so also ob das
überhaupt mir gelingen wird ich bin sehr
gespannt komm den Rand rein ich mache
das wirklich so wie ich es gelernt habe
vergiss nicht nun zuruck zu ja also
Grüße an uns ja von Norden nach Süden
und so und jetzt heißt es Formen Alter
ich habe so das Gefühl das ist einfach
schon was anderes also so wie der sich
wieder sich verhält wie der sich zieht
und so ist ein anderer Teig auf jeden
Fall sieht aber nicht verkehrt aus jetzt
von meinem Auge sage ich mal gute gute
Größe eigentlich alles gut ne jetzt ist
es einfach ne also nehmen uns unsere
Stücke den Tomaten drauf einmal rund
ausformen ich sage ehrlich
selbstgemachte Pizzateig vernünftiger
Ofen auch günstige Zutaten wenn
garantiert immer gutes Ergebnis erzeugen
gerade bei Pizza ja ganz ursprünglich
auch so ein arme Leute essen war das ist
ja das Herz von dem Gericht irgendwo
auch ne aber wie gut es halt ne das
müssen wir herausfinden das tut mir ein
bisschen weh den günstigen Käse zu
benutzen ich mache das so damit wir das
so vergleichbar optisch hinbekommen
mache ich den auch in so kleinen
Häufchen weil wir haben ja gleich hier
so ein bisschen größere Schnitzer von
unserem anderen Käse mir auch gespannt
wie der Rand auf die wird auf die
überhaupt aufgeht und so das ist halt
genau das ist halt die große Stärke vom
Mehl das ist unsere erste Pizza hier ist
unsere Pizza und ich finde man sieht
jetzt in dem Zustand schon dass es ein
günstige Pizza ist zumindest am
geriebenen Käse genau an den Käse kann
halt einfach nichts vorbei täuschen so
wie viel Luft im Teig ist es auch auf
jeden Fall ein Unterschied wir schieben
sie in den Ofen
bereit sein der Pilz also der Rand geht
auf jeden Fall riecht schon schwarz
bisschen
doch oha ja kann sich sehen lassen also
ich habe wenig Erfahrung mit dieser Art
Pizza sieht eigentlich gut aus ne sehr
sehr gut aus ja schauen wir mal wie das
Ergebnis wird so meine Männer ich habe
eine Pizza wisst ihr welches Video wir
drehen oder seid ihr einfach nur zu
einem Pizza Test gekommen okay denn ihr
müsst mir nur sagen welche Pizza besser
sein wird diese hier oder die die ich
euch als nächstes reichen werden die
sieht schon mal nicht so gut aus wie
deine Pizzen sonst so viel will ich
schon mal sagen leo ist der gierigste
so schnell geht so eine Pizza weg
oh aber ist geil ist richtig geil
schmeckt deutlich besser als die
aussieht
ich finde so die Tomatensoße schmeckt so
richtig so
fruchtig frisch so herzhaft aber auch
sehr gute Pizza ja
alle wieder weg ich rufe euch gleich
noch eine weitere Pizza zu testen geben
oder was eines Tages wirst du es
herausfinden jetzt kann ich wieder offen
sprechen und ich muss sagen die Pizza
war richtig lecker also wirklich die hat
auch so schön frisch selbst gebacken
also es war auf jeden Fall eine wirklich
gute Pizza der Teig ist mein größtes
Manko also ich weiß nicht ob ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht habe euch
irgendwas vergessen habe aber er ist auf
jeden Fall nicht so schön aufgegangen
ich hoffe hier sieht das besser aus wenn
bei unserem schönen Mehl was wir hier
drin haben sollte das ganze auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen anders aussehen zack
perfekt wir fahren einmal unseren Rand
und der Teig ist wirklich mehrlich
weicher also das ist so als würde man so
ein Baby bauch rein Piepsen
nehmen wir uns unsere Tomatensoße die
mir schon echt gut gefallen hat auch bei
der anderen Pizza Tomaten aus der Dose
die ja immer reif geerntet und dann ein
konserviert werden schmecken schon mal
krasser als wenn man jetzt irgendwas aus
frischen tomatensaugen zumindest hier
bei uns in Deutschland dazu dann einfach
ein bisschen Salz und das hat einfach
schon wirklich viel Geschmack so kannst
du wirklich gar nichts sagen jetzt
nehmen wir uns unseren ferdin Latte
gegen den auch so ein bisschen einen
kleinen Teilchen drüber das ist schon
wieder ne das ist wirklich krass also
Pizza margreta ist wirklich magisch weil
sie so einfach und so gut deshalb ab
damit in den Ofen und wir sehen uns beim
Probieren
[Musik]
es geht schon eher in die Richtung von
den Pizzen die wir vom Maxi gewohnt sind
ne ich sag gar nichts meine Männer nehmt
euch alle gerne ein Stück probiert und
schmeckt denn es kommt vor allem auch
okay
[Musik]
gespannt was ihr sagen werdet es ist
einfach nur so ein bisschen mehr Crunch
da also der der Rand hier fühlt sich
einfach ein bisschen besonderer an habe
den klaren Favoriten überhaupt nicht
also ich würde beides wissen ich bin
beides auch übelst gut das sind so nur
außen für mich die die super super
schwierigsten ja ich fand die erste
besser ja weil der Teig ich finde jetzt
der der Teig nimmt zu viel also nimmt
mir zu viel Geschmack von der Soße weg
und bei der ersten Geschmack so der hat
so richtig was eingenommen machen das
einfach wir sind fünf Leute wir sind
jetzt die Jury wer fand die erste Pizza
besser
also wir anderen drei fanden die zweite
Pizza besser aber ich weiß auch dass die
zweite Pizza 7 mal teurer war
das heißt wir haben ultra teures
Olivenöl hat wahrscheinlich keiner was
von geschmeckt ne wir haben das richtig
ein anderes Mehl beim ersten so dass der
Rand ein bisschen höher geht das ist ein
bisschen Fluff also ich finde es
merklich fluffiger schon so ne das bei
einem anderen ist ein ganz normales 405
aber ich muss auch sagen für mich weil
die große Überraschung wie nah die
eigentlich geschmacklich vor allem
beieinander sind gerade so die
Tomatensoße wo ich dachte riesen
Unterschied fand ich beim ersten auch
richtig gut bei dem einfach nur Tomaten
mit Salz ich muss gerade fast weinen
der gesamte Einkauf mit Zutaten für
mindestens vier Pizzen 9,36 € und
mindestens 4 14 bei der anderen Pizza
71,52 €. also es ist vor allem halt so
so viele rein wie es Olivenöl aber auch
die Tomaten sind fast viermal so teuer
der Käse ist viermal so teuer es ist
alles teurer aber der Unterschied ist
echt nicht so groß wie gedacht man muss
aber auch dazu sagen du testest auf
einem Niveau wo du einen unheimlich
krassen Ofen schon da hast und du
Erfahrung hast vielleicht würde das ein
größeren Unterschied machen wenn man
nicht überall so krass professionelle
Equipment hätte und vielleicht würde das
würden die Tomaten mehr ausmachen wenn
man jetzt bei 200 Grad in einem normalen
Ofen die die Pizza Scheiße macht oder
aber vielleicht wenn man noch besser ist
oder also so so z.B der Pizzabäcker nun
wenn der das machen würde der können
natürlich dann aus jedem Teig jedem
Rohling alles rauskitzeln so was
verschwindend ähnlich also für mich ist
in dem Fall der eigentliche Sieger auf
jeden Fall auch der günstigere Teig
danke dass ihr eure professionellen
Gaumen geliehen habt das war sehr schön
mit euch ich packe jetzt noch ein paar
Pizza ich habe nämlich eine ordentlich
Teig übrig wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal wieder schreibt in die Kommentare ob
ihr das jemals gedacht hättet was ihr
eure Favorit gewesen bis zum nächsten
Mal macht's gut und Ciao jetzt mal
wieder für euch ciao